good morning everyone yeah there we go
you've got more enthusiasm for me than
for Kurt that's the way it should be so
I'm really happy too yeah good a mate
how's it going okay so Kurt asked me to
start off my talk this morning by
introducing myself to you so my first
slide is Who am I as Kurt's already made
fun of I sound funny because I come to
Australia from Australia luckily I
wasn't eaten by a dingo when I was a
baby okay so I kind of as a kid I
perhaps wasn't like all of you guys and
necessarily that passionate about
science I spent most of sort of my teens
chasing a little tennis ball around the
tennis court and up until I reached 15
and realized i was going to stay this
small and never grow anymore I thought I
was going to become a professional
tennis player at age of 15 I was still
this height wasn't getting any bigger so
I needed to do something else I did my
undergraduate in Australia and I thought
I was going to be a mathematician but I
had a chemistry professor who I found
inspiring I did research with him and my
career has kind of stayed in chemistry
all the way through until I've arrived
at Yale where I work here so I don't
just work by myself I have a great team
which I'm fortunate enough to be a part
of two of my team or three of my team
are here today they're going to help out
with some demonstrations so that's
Louise and he won sitting in the front
row and together me and my team so this
is the full team here well except for
these two guys here who you can see a
photo bombed picture we're interested in
converting carbon dioxide into useful
materials and i'll talk more about this
throughout today's talk but this is a
topic which is not
of interest to people at Yale are my
group and I are also part of the team
which includes researchers at Brown
University in Rhode Island and together
we've formed a larger group of
scientists which who are interested in
this general problem of trying to
convert carbon dioxide into useful
materials so our center is called the
Center for the capture and conversion of
co2 okay so what am I going to tell you
about we're going to start off today by
explaining to you guys why we think what
we're doing is important why is it
perhaps going to solve problems that we
as a society are currently encountering
and to do this I'm going to explain to
you what is global warming what is
carbon dioxide and how can we use carbon
dioxide as an alternative feedstock then
i'm going to give you some tools so that
you can understand the science that we
do so you might not know the answers to
these questions at the moment what a
catalyst why use transition metals but I
hope in today's talk I will explain
those to you and then we'll finish off
by presenting some of our scientific
results and in all three of these
sections will try and do some
demonstrations so you can see firsthand
what we actually do in the lab and how
we perform our experiments okay so let's
start off with a very big picture
question you've all probably heard about
global warming but what exactly is
global warming so global warming is the
increase in temperature of the Earth's
atmosphere and oceans so let's have a
look at some data if we have a look at
this graph and if we set 1950 as being
zero degrees you can see that in the
years before nineteen fifty the
temperatures were colder than they are
now we're in the years after nineteen
fifty the temperature has gradually been
increasing so this is the average global
temperature of both the air
and the oceans and furthermore you can
see that of the 13 warmest years since
eighteen eighty which is when our
records go back to 11 of them have been
in the years 2001 to 2011 scientists
have started to try and predict what is
going to happen to global temperature
over the next hundred years and even if
we take the most conservative value you
can see that they predict there's going
to be an average increase in the
temperature of around two degrees
Celsius by the year 2100 in the most
conservative case and up to five degrees
Celsius in the most extreme case so what
are the potential effects both for the
environment and also for us of global
warming well we have a lot of ice on the
planet at the moment and if the
temperatures rise that ice is going to
melt if that ice melts the sea levels
will rise and this will result in the
extinction of some species which require
that ice to survive so here we have a
polar bear who's stuck as his iceberg is
melting so this will lead to an increase
in heat waves and droughts so these are
kind of the predicted changes to our
climate which are a potential
consequence of global warming what are
the potential implications for us well
one if there's less land that we can
farm this can mean a decrease in food
supplies which could obviously have
catastrophic areas if you're fortunate
or perhaps unfortunate enough to own a
beachside property as the sea level
increases your beachside property could
incur it could flood and also there have
been studies which believe that there
could be a negative effect on human
health because of problems with
respiration as the global temperature
increases so what causes global warming
right what can we do if we understand
what causes it
maybe this will allow us to understand
how we can prevent it so there are a
number of gases which are known as
greenhouse gases and these essentially
trap heat in the Earth's atmosphere and
greenhouse gases are some very common
materials they're things like water
vapor carbon dioxide methane and ozone
and actually greenhouse gases are
essential for our survival if there were
no are naturally occur in greenhouse
gases the temperatures on earth would be
approximately 59 degrees Fahrenheit
colder than they are right now so
imagine if today was 59 degrees colder
it would be worse than when we had the
polar vortex okay but the problem is
what happens if we put extra greenhouse
gases in the atmosphere right what
happens if we're generating more carbon
dioxide well then we get global warming
and the reality is that carbon dioxide
is by far the greenhouse gas that we are
responsible for putting in to the
atmosphere in far larger quantities than
would be naturally occurring so what is
carbon dioxide just a reminder for some
of you in terms of chemistry it's a cus
central carbon atom which is bonded to
oxygen atoms and under normal
circumstances carbon dioxide is a gas so
you can't see it or smell it there's
lots of carbon dioxide already in the
ocean and a potential consequence of
rises in are the temperature is this the
carbon dioxide in the ocean will be
released and caused even more global
warming and a problem is that as a
society we currently don't have very
many uses for carbon dioxide does anyone
know what some of the uses for carbon
dioxide are where do you probably
encounter carbon dioxide every day does
anyone in here like to drink soft drinks
right people drink Coke okay
a coke has carbon dioxide's so some of
you might be too old but if you guys
ever seen the candy pop rocks okay I
need a volunteer who wants to try some
of these pop rocks all right you're the
closest so you can do this right I want
you can open it up and then we're going
to ask you what happens when you eat the
pop rock okay so we use co2 in fire
extinguishers probably the major
industrial use of co2 is in urea this is
a compound which is used as a fertilizer
it's also used in explosives and in
glues and in the automobile industry and
here we have some solid carbon dioxide
which also has several uses and we're
going to do some demonstrations with
that in a minute okay what's your name
tunisia okay you're going to try some of
these pop rocks for us okay put them in
your mouth and tell us what what happens
it's popping right because a pop-rock
essentially has dissolved carbon dioxide
little carbon dioxide bubbles in this
solid and when your saliva comes in
contact with the solid it dissolves it
and it releases the carbon dioxide so
you can feel this tingling sensation in
your mouth as the carbon dioxide is
released and we have many more pop rocks
which will hand out over the course of
today's lecture okay so carbon dioxide
is a gas at room temperature but if you
freeze it it can become a solid Lewis
you want to show everyone some solid
carbon dioxide so there you can see we
have some dry ice it's called pellets
and these are commonly used as a
material for cooling substances because
a solid dry ice pellet as it becomes a
solid at a temperature of about minus 78
degrees Celsius so if I try and hold on
to this for too long I'm going to burn
my hand but an interesting property of
carbondale
oxide is can you guys see this here we
put a few more pellets dump I'm going to
leave that here and by the end of the
lecture you're not going to be able to
see the carbon dioxide but you're not
going to see a liquid that's because at
this pressure carbon dioxide Sublime's
so it goes directly from a solid to a
gas okay so now we have some balloons
one of these balloons is full of
nitrogen we have another balloon which
is full of carbon dioxide and then we're
going to get some liquid nitrogen and
Louise is going to take the balloon full
of n2 and she's going to put it in
liquid nitrogen liquid nitrogen does
anyone know how cold liquid nitrogen is
it's minus 196 degrees Celsius so that's
a lot colder than the polar vortex ok
we're going to dip the n2 balloon in
there okay maybe we're not ok well let's
this balloon is full of carbon dioxide
ok we prepared it earlier on we're going
to dip the balloon full of carbon
dioxide in there what do you guys think
is going to happen I said carbon dioxide
becomes a solid at minus 78 liquid
nitrogen is at minus 196 louise is going
to pull the balloon out and look at that
and she's going to shake it it's like a
maraca right that's the solid carbon
dioxide in there and then we're slowly
going to watch the balloon our return to
its normal state
okay so that's some of the properties of
carbon dioxide which mean that you know
when the carbon dioxide is in this
balloon we can't see it we can't smell
it right you can just see the balloon
what Louise is going to do while I keep
talking and she's going to fill up a
glove with our dry ice am I going to see
what happens to that and she's also
going to put some dry ice in that coke
bottle and then put a balloon on top of
that coke bottle and later on in the
talk we'll come back to that okay so we
are releasing carbon dioxide into the
atmosphere that's what's perhaps causing
global warming and why do we make this
correlation we make this correlation
because here i have a plot of the
increase in the global average
temperature and the increase in co2
concentration in the atmosphere and you
can see that both of these lines follow
exactly the same trend and on that basis
we believe that carbon dioxide or an
increase in carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere is responsible for global
warming and the reality is the level of
carbon dioxide in the atmosphere is
greater at the present time than in any
other point in the last 800,000 years
okay so where is all of this carbon
dioxide coming from so we all like to do
things which require energy so how many
of you arrived here by car okay most of
us arrived here by guy anyone walk okay
I'm probably the only one who walked so
in order to power your car you typically
use a petroleum and this comes from oil
and oil coal and natural gas are types
of fossil fuels so fossil fuels are
formed by natural processes but it takes
a very long time
or these fossil fuels to form and
currently or if we look at 2006 almost
eighty percent of our energy comes from
fossil fuels okay so all of the things
that we know and love to do using a
computer using TV heating our place need
these fossil fuels and these fossil
fuels release co2 when we burn them and
that is bad from the environment because
it's causing global warming it's also
true that accessible sources of fossil
fuels are running out and this means we
need another energy source both in order
to continue with our current lifestyle
but also to preserve our environment so
you guys have probably all heard of some
kinds of renewable energy sources they
are for example wind energy energy from
biofuels and the big one is solar energy
and I'm not going to talk to you about
these things today but as a society in
the next 50 years is probably imperative
for us to transition to these
alternative sources of energy and many
people both at Yale and in other
universities and industries in the world
are working to try and create these
alternative energies but there is a
problem with changing to these
alternative energies and that comes from
the fact that at the moment most of the
products that we engage with are
actually derived from the petrochemical
industry so what do I mean by this let's
take a barrel of oil and about fifty
percent of the oil slightly more is used
for gasoline liquefied petroleum heavy
fuel oil but about a third of the oil is
used to make other products and other
distal eighths ok so at the moment many
products that we use in
everyday life come from oil so what are
these products okay so all the paint
which was used on this room cosmetics
right if you're like me you want to gel
your hair you want to look pretty that
comes from the cosmic comes from oil you
know this morning I had a bath i had my
rubber ducky the rubber ducky also comes
from petroleum products you've all got
water bottles in front of you they use
plastics that comes from oil okay your
cars have many components cleaning
agents and you know all of these types
of small gadgets which are used in
functioning machines so if we stop using
oil how are we going to make these
important products so at the moment we
have about 1 to 5 carbon sources which
are oil natural gas coal the things that
produce greenhouse gases like co2 and a
bad for the environment and we don't
want to use them we convert them to
about 100 based chemicals so these are
things like acrylic acid ethylene formic
acid and then they're converted into
even more chemicals which are the
chemicals which are in all of the
products around us in contrast to that
carbon dioxide which is our most
abundant source of carbon is basically
not used as a feedstock for any of these
products and what we want to do is we
want to flip this cycle around so
instead of using oil and natural gas as
our carbon feedstock to make all the
products that we know and love we want
to use carbon dioxide as our feedstock
okay so why do we want to use carbon
dioxide as a feedstock it's readily
available it's non-toxic and it's cheap
and so I have a little video which
summarizes the center that I'm involved
in which will illustrate everything that
I've just shown using an animation
okay so that's the challenge or the
problem that we're trying to solve let's
go back and have a look at our balloons
and our gloves so you can see look at
what's happened to these gloves that
louise has put co2 in the co2 has
sublimed and they've now expanded and
our balloon on top of our coke bottle
has also expanded as the co2 has sublime
and they're going to keep expanding and
we might be in for a shock later on I in
the lecture okay so we know what we want
to do how are we going to do it right
it's hard to convert carbon dioxide into
anything useful part of the reason it's
such a potent greenhouse gas is it just
stays in the atmosphere it doesn't do
anything it's there for hundreds of
thousands of years so once we put it in
we're stuck with it and it's stable
because it doesn't really react with
other molecules right there's some
things you know if I take one molecule
in another model molecule I'll readily
make something new with carbon dioxide
that is extremely hard to do so the
question that we have to answer is how
do we increase the rate at which two
chemicals react with each other I want
to take carbon dioxide I want to take
something else and I want to make
something new how do I make that happen
and this is the background to the
science that we do in our lab and so a
substance that will increase the rate of
a reaction is known as a catalyst and a
catalyst is a particularly important
substance because a catalyst will
increase the rate of the reaction but it
won't be consumed in the reaction so I
get it back at the end of the reaction
in the same form that i put it in and
catalysts are used every day in society
so almost ninety percent of the millions
of chemicals that are produced are
produced you
catalyst so let's see how a catalyst
works so if I have a plus B right and a
plus B could be something like carbon
monoxide plus hydrogen if I have two
tanks one of carbon diox-- what carbon
monoxide and one of hydrogen and I mix
them together nothing is going to happen
I can leave them for 500,000 years
nothing is going to happen if I take a
tank of carbon diox-- of carbon monoxide
and hydrogen and I add a small amount of
the catalyst I can produce gasoline in
minutes right and what this small amount
of catalyst is doing is it's
facilitating this reaction which would
inherently otherwise be extremely slow
so how can we consider that for every
chemical reaction there is a certain
amount of energy which needs to be put
into the system to facilitate that
reaction if i add a catalyst I decrease
the amount of energy that I need to put
in and by decreasing the amount of
energy that I need to put in I increase
the rate of the reaction so typically a
catalyst will interact with are the
molecules that are reacting but at the
end of the reaction it will come out in
the same form that it went in so here we
can see an energy profile for a reaction
so you start off with your reactants
they interact with the catalyst which is
called em then we need to put in some
energy to go over a barrier and then you
get another product an intermediate
which has the catalyst bound we go over
another barrier and we get our product
and a catalyst bound and we can draw
this as a cycle because our catalyst is
able to go round and round converting
our reactant to our product in principle
a catalyst is recoverable but often
industrially we can't recover it okay so
let me give you an analogy that will
help you understand how a catalyst works
let's say I want to go I want to go over
a really big hill okay so you guys are
young and fit you probably have the
energy to go all the way over that hill
but I'm old I'm slow I don't have enough
energy to go over there so I need a
catalyst to help me so what would be the
equivalent of the catalyst let's say I
built a pathway through the hill like a
tunnel right that tunnel is a lower
energy paths which will get me from one
side of the hill to the other without
having to put in anywhere near as much
effort so that's what a catalyst is
analogous to in terms of an example we
can all understand ok so the beauty of a
catalyst is I can put in one molecule of
catalyst and I can make up to a million
model molecules of product so for
example if we look at one of these water
bottles these water bottles were made
using a catalyst and the catalyst is so
good that the catalyst is still in this
water bottle it's a zirconium catalyst
and they put in one molecule of the
catalyst to make a million molecules of
the plastic and therefore there's so
little zirconium in here that it doesn't
need to be removed before it's safe for
us to drink from this bottle ok so we
need some way of measuring how good a
catalyst is right we want to know if we
make a new catalyst in our lab is that
any good and we can measure how
efficient a catalyst is by looking at
two quantities the turnover number and
the turnover frequency so the turnover
number is if I put in one molecule of
catalyst how many molecules of product
do I make the turnover frequency is how
fast do I do it because that's important
if my catalyst will give me a million
molecules of product but it will take a
hundred thousand years
that's probably not very good for
practical purposes i won a catalyst
which will turn over a hundred thousand
times in a minute and then I'll get my
product very quickly okay so let's give
you guys are an example so let's
consider a reaction that has 1% catalyst
loading so this means they have one
molecule of catalyst to 100 molecules of
substrate if I get eighty percent of my
product at the end of the reaction how
many times is my catalyst turning over
does anyone have any ideas okay the
number of times the catalyst turns over
is how many molecules of product am I
going to get so here I'm getting 80
molecules of product and I put in one
molecule of catalyst so how many times
is it turning over 80 right good you get
some more pop rocks okay so it turns
over 80 times in two hours so how many
times does that mean my catalyst is
turning over per hour 40 right so 40 is
my turn over frequency okay but
typically a chemical reaction doesn't go
at a constant rate so if you look at the
graph down the bottom you can see that
the chemical reaction goes fast at the
start and then slows down so we often
just look at this initial rate to get
the turnover frequency so these are some
of the chemical tools for assessing how
good my catalyst is but how many of you
guys want to be rich okay so if you want
to Kurt once the beach so if you want to
be rich and I come to you with my
catalyst and I say my catalyst turns
over a hundred thousand times and Kurt
comes to you and he says his catalyst
turns over a million times and maybe
Kurt's catalyst also turns over faster
than my catalyst but does that mean
you're going to use Kurt's catalyst and
not my catalyst
what other things do you have to
consider price right how expensive is
the catalyst how selective is the
catalyst does it give one product only
or does it give a mixture of products so
there are other factors which are
important in determining whether or not
your catalyst is going to be practically
useful so what we want to do is we want
to develop catalysts for carbon dioxide
conversion I just told you that carbon
dioxide is a very Wow there we go we
just lost one of our balloons right it
filled up with too much carbon dioxide
and a burst but we want to come up with
a way of converting carbon dioxide into
reactive species and we need to discover
catalyst so in particular my group uses
transition metal catalyst and we don't
have a periodic table in here but
periodic in the periodic table
transition metals are a specific group
of metals does anyone know some examples
of transition metals yeah I an right I n
is one of the most abundant transition
metals anyone else have any ideas on
transition metals gold is gold the
transition metal will give you gold it's
somewhat our icon you can come we can
come down at the end gold okay what else
but copper okay what else but it
titanium yep silver okay so there are
probably around 20 28 to 30 transition
metals and the reason that we use them
is that you can very easily control the
properties of the transition metal so
how can we change the properties of the
transition metal we change the
properties by changing what is connected
to the transition metal okay so here we
have some beakers and these beakers all
contain nickel which has six water
molecules bound to it so you can see we
get this beautiful green
fella whose favorite color is green yes
some people do you guys like this green
ok so what I'm going to show you of what
he won and Louise are going to
demonstrate is that we can change the
properties and one of the properties of
a compound is its color by changing
what's bound to nickel so first what
they're going to do is they're going to
take some nickel and they're going to
add ammonia which is nh3 to the nickel
solution Luisi is pouring it in now and
she's going to stir stir stir stir
Louise stir so you guys can you see
what's happening what color is it gone
blue and we've also had a little bit of
solid precipitate out and the reason
that that's happened is we've replaced
the water molecules which are bound to
nickel with some ammonia molecules and
clearly you can see that we've changed
the properties of the nickel by doing
that and we've gone from a green
compound to a blue compound question
also I've written the chemical formula
for ammonia so like carbon dioxide is
co2 ammonia is nh3 it's comprised of one
nitrogen atom and three hydrogen atoms
ok so we could use ammonia to go from
green to from green to blue we can add a
different compound and this compound is
known as ethylene diamine and we're just
going to add one molecule of ethylene
diamine compared to the nickel Louise he
won you're ready okay let's watch the
beaker he was going to pour into you can
see she's going to stir stir stir and
now we get a much more vibrant and
beautiful blue in my opinion because
we've made a different compound where
we've now replaced two water molecules
with one equivalent of ethylene diamine
okay so we can change the properties
even more now we're going to take our
ammonia compound and to our ammonia
compound we're going to add one
equivalent of our ethylene diamine he
won Louise are we ready okay so this is
the beaker in the middle no I want to
add it to this guy okay so we're going
to add one equivalent of ethylene
diamine to that one are we ready okay
let's go here one and then we're going
to stir Wow and we get another color
change and now you can see that the
color of this molecule which has four
ammonia's and one ethylene diamine is
different to the color of this molecule
which has four waters and one ethylene
diamine and so finally what we're going
to do is we're going to replace all of
the waters or ammonia with ethylene
diamine so we're going to make this
molecule which only has ethylene diamine
coordinated to it so we can do it to the
end beaker just by adding a lot of
ethylene diamine you can see we now get
this beautiful vibrant purple and if we
take some ethylene diamine and we add it
to our ammonia solution with one
ethylene diamine in the middle so second
from left goes we're going to get the
same color
okay and you're going to see that change
to the same as the far beaker so what
this is showing you a question okay so
if you imagine you have water and you
put sodium chloride into the water the
sodium chloride will dissolve right but
what happens if I keep adding sodium
chloride eventually I would have added
so much sodium chloride that it will no
longer be dissolved in the water so in
the case of that compound we had so much
of the compound that it was no longer
soluble and because we're making four
different solute four different
compounds they have different
solubilities and so some of them are
less soluble than other ones and we're
starting to precipitate out okay so you
know color is one property that i can
change is not particularly interesting
property in terms of me facilitating
chemical reactions but it's great as a
demonstration for you guys another
property of transition metal complexes
is that they are very reactive so we
can't do it in a lecture hall but there
are transition metal compounds that my
group works with which will
spontaneously react with dioxygen and
they'll catch fire but that's good
because carbon dioxide is an extremely
stable molecule so we need something
that is very reactive that is going to
be able to react with that and so what
we can do is we can take now we have a
nickel compound it has different are
molecules bound to it and we can bind
carbon dioxide or we can take a uranium
compound and we can bind carbon dioxide
and what happens is that when we bind
carbon dioxide to the metal we change
its properties we might make it more
reactive and you can think of this as
being like a tug-of-war where now the
metal is binding to carbon dioxide and
weakening it
and then something else can come in and
react with the carbon dioxide whereas if
the metal wasn't reacting with the
carbon dioxide it would be much less
reactive you're having two opposite
forces act on carbon dioxide okay so let
me spend the last 10 minutes telling you
a little bit about the actual science
that my group does so the particular
question that we're interested in is can
we take carbon dioxide and make this
chemical formic acid so here is formic
acid all right it's this molecule here
it has one carbon two oxygens and two
hydrogen's and we use a lot of this
compound about seven hundred and twenty
thousand tons per year we use it for a
variety of applications including
insecticides for tanning leather goods
and the way we make it at the moment is
not optimal because basically we take
methanol and carbon monoxide and we make
this molecule methyl formate then we can
convert the methyl formate to formic
acid but to do this we need two huge use
a huge amount of water and then you have
to separate the water from the formic
acid this is a very expensive process
alternatively you can take your methyl
formate and you can add ammonia you can
make the a mate and then you can
hydrolyze it to make formic acid but if
you use this route you generate all of
this ammonium sulfate and you now have a
waste product which is not useful and
what we want to do is we want to take
hydrogen and co2 and make formic acid so
you can see that in principle there's no
waste products from this reaction right
all of our reactants are being
incorporated into our product so what
God has started in this a group in Japan
had shown that you could take an Iridium
compound so now we have a periodic table
and
you can see that iridium is here so it's
one of the transition metals you can
take this iridium compound you can take
h2 and co2 and you can make formic acid
and this catalysts are pretty good they
turn over about 3.5 million times okay
that's great for a catalyst if it has a
high turnover number but the problem is
this catalyst doesn't work in water and
if you want to do something commercially
to make formic acid on a large scale
people want a catalyst which works in
water so what my group did was we wanted
to look at this catalyst we wanted to
understand how it works and then we
wanted to see if we could do that
chemistry in water so the first thing we
noticed was that if you take this
iridium compound you have this iridium
attached to a hydride this reacts with
co2 and it makes a new compound where
you have a ridium oxygen and you have
carbon hydrogen but this reaction is not
very energetically favorable and what
that means is that if I remove the co2
from this compound it goes back to this
compound right and that makes it
difficult to study I can't isolate this
molecule so my group did some theory
right we modeled how could we change our
complex just like we change the
properties of the colors of these nickel
complexes how could we modify our
iridium complex to make it more
favorable for it to interact with co2
which might help us design a better
catalyst so to do that we played with
the ligand or we played with what was
bound to iridium directly opposite this
hydride so we put all different kinds of
elements from the periodic table
opposite this high drive and our
calculations would tell us how favorable
this reaction with co2 would be and our
calculations predicted that one molecule
this molecule here
would interact in a significantly more
favorable manner with carbon dioxide so
what we did was we made that compound in
the lab we were able to prove that we
made that compound I won't tell you how
but we did that and then we took that
compound and we reacted it with co2 and
we were able to get this compound here
here you can see the molecular drawing
of this compound and quite clearly co2
is incorporated into it and we were able
to get this compound and we could store
it outside in the atmosphere so we got
good agreement between our experiment
and our theory but what we wanted to do
was we wanted to use this compound for
catalysis in water could we take this
compound at h2 and co2 and make formic
acid and the answer is yes we could do
this and we could get about 350,000
turnovers so one molecule of iridium
generated 350,000 molecules of formic
acid that's pretty good it's not as good
as the system that we started off with
but our system works in water so I said
at the start that this thing is a
catalyst so what is our catalytic cycle
so here we have this compound we believe
that it interacts with the hydrogen
right that releases something in the
form of formate or formic acid and makes
a new compound that compound is
converted to a different compound which
then reacts with co2 to get us back to
our starting point ok so our catalyst is
not being altered in this reaction all
that's happening is it's facilitating
co2 + h2 going to formate or formic acid
so you would think that the problem is
solved does anyone know where we get
iridium from how many people had heard
of iridium before this talk yeah you
know where we go to rediem front where
you've heard of iridium
for meteors right so here we have a
graph of the most common elements in and
let's look at that so if we look at that
look where iridium is and this is on a
log scale which means these gaps are
even more large than they appear iridium
is right down the bottom it's the least
abundant metal so what does this mean
about iridium there's not much and if
there's not much it means it's going to
be expensive right look at the other
things which are around iridium things
like platinum gold the type of things
that people like as rings right they're
expensive gifts but that's no good for
making a chemical if we want to make use
these as a catalyst in a high turnover
process on a large scale we want to use
something which is cheap okay so what
are the things with your cheap things
like iron manganese titanium so as you
go down the periodic table things tend
to get more expensive and more rare so
we are now trying to do this same
chemistry on iron that we're doing on
iridium we've again managed we need to
make an iron complex and we've been able
to do that and we've been able to prove
that we make these intermediates so here
are some molecular structures and we now
have an iron system which is
catalytically active we can take h2 and
co2 and we can make for me or formic
acid there's only one problem so our
Iridium catalyst turned over 350,000
times our iron catalyst only turns over
17 times and so that's not good enough
and what we're doing in our group at the
moment is we're trying to improve this
iron catalyst so that it has comparable
reactivity to iridium and then it might
be practical for people to use for co2
conversion so let me tell you what we're
trying to do we're trying to develop
catalyst
the incorporation of co2 into catalyst
into fine chemicals we have something
which might be able to make formic acid
which is one commodity chemical but if
you go back to that slide at the start
where I said well we need to make the
hundreds of thousands of chemicals and
we need to make these five base
chemicals from co2 we still have a long
way to go and with this team at Brown
some of the other chemicals that we're
trying to make from carbon dioxide our
acrylic acid so acrylic acid is used in
super absorbent polymers methanol which
is used as a feedstock for this
production of many chemicals and
ethylene which is used to make a lot of
plastics okay so this is sort of the
full team that I work with Louise and he
won I don't do any of the work I talked
about today but they're part of the team
so I think we've got time so I want to
finish off with one more sort of video
in this video shows a catalytic reaction
and so it comes from a scientist in
England and this reaction he's doing the
opposite to what we're trying to do he
is trying to liberate co2 from a
reaction but you're going to see exactly
what happens when he adds his catalyst
you
okay so there you go that was an example
of an actual catalytic reaction so I
hope you enjoyed the lecture this
morning thank you very much for coming
and I'm happy to answer any questions